Karin is with us in Spokane Washington
hi Karen how are you I'm good thanks are
you better than I deserve what's up well
I got a couple things going I've been
doing envelope systems before I think
maybe you were even around but anyway
the deal I've got is I met my husband he
has 13 credit cards maxed out they're
all paid off but now we have not been
away for college and my son's going to
college in June do I join the college in
this June yes and you have no money well
exactly I mean so now they're away they
said we don't qualify for any grants or
anything
why because we make too much they said
what's your household income 77 why is
he going in June he graduates in June
and he's going to a tech school in June
a tech school well what does it cost
it's going to be thirty thousand up
front yes well they told us we need to
do take a loan out I'm sure they did
yeah what's he studying he's gonna be a
diesel mechanic and they want you to
prepay this yes do they not have a plan
where you pay for semesters as you go
okay well yeah well they said we need to
get a loan on and they'll pay the
college or whatever expect to do well
sure they did but I'm not gonna go take
out a $30,000 loan to be a diesel
mechanic
no thank you I'll pass so the answer is
no now let's back into that and figure
out what we can do that's what I was
trying to do so I don't give a crap what
they said all they want your money yeah
so um the answer is no now let's figure
it out now how often do they how long is
the diesel school it's only nine months
Oh
thirty thousand bucks for nine months
yeah that's freaking the price of
Harvard have you thought about that
well no I look at our local school at
unity school he can go for two years for
fifteen Walled uh yeah we're going
community okay so why would we pay
double
I don't know cuz he wants to go to this
oh well I don't care he's dumb and broke
and young and you're his mom and you're
gonna tell him no I'm well I mean why
would you finance thirty thousand bucks
for nine months when you can go for 24
months for fifteen well I thought that
they're saying oh we get him out we get
him in the job quicker and yeah that's
what that's because they want their
thirty thousand bucks yeah if you can
work on listen them if your local vote X
school Community College would
definitely set you up set him up for a
job as much as coming out of this other
diesel college also know I'm not paying
them 30 grand I'm not going to pay him
double to get him out a few months
earlier absolutely not
no way no how I'm glad you didn't have
the thirty thousand cash because you
would have given it to him I wouldn't
yes yeah so no bad idea plus it's good
for him to get in there and start
studying for a little while and and you
know when he's once he gets his hands
dirty up to his elbows and this stuff he
may figure out this isn't what he wants
to do and you don't want to be all the
way into this deal well exactly that was
fine okay why wait do this he wouldn't
be the first kid to quit school true so
so when does the one the Community
College star probably the fall right
yeah I have anyone we've kind of looked
at well this other guy from this other
school told it so I don't even think
they're gonna have a class this year so
yeah our competitors not selling anymore
I like that I should try that you think
yeah yeah they're not selling books over
there at that other place where the only
people got books that would work are you
really going to stop this from happening
or am I wasting my time oh no I'm going
to stop it before I get xx just when I'm
put to sign something possibly so ok
answer's no we can't go there for two
reasons one is its double and two is its
double and three is we're not going into
debt actually that's three reasons and
so how would you say your household
income was again okay so you need 15,000
to do one year by the fall and your son
is in college graduating from high
school in June yeah
so he's going to be working all summer
you guys are going to be saving like
crazy and then while he's in school he's
also going to be working so we can pay
cash for the next year when it comes
around right okay actually for the 10
years so Oh 15 for two years so we need
7,000 bucks is all yes the whole shebang
that's awesome yeah yeah I think this is
a better plan okay cuz I gotta tell you
I gotta tell you when I go get my car
worked on I don't ask where they went to
school exactly do that well my brother
went to this school and he did fine he's
making over six figures so he went to
this expensive school no no no that
Community College oh really
yeah okay and so uh what have you asked
him about this I have it um I don't know
if you say I'd heard of this other
company I just you know I think he's
gonna tell you the same thing your
common sense was telling you and I
already told you okay perfect isn't he
perfect
well then he can see it he can live at
home and go at this place I have Issa
it's at a state yes to go 1,400 miles
away from me yeah well I'm glad you
didn't have 30 grand because you almost
made a bad decision cool that's good I'm
glad you call thank you
you